[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rosen the
executive director here at long now it's
great to see a sellout crowd for
algorithms nice actually known Brian for
quite a while he's been coming to these
talks for years mostly at the behest of
Rose his now fiance congratulations so
yeah it was part of her wooing strategy
apparently is what she just told these
four years of long now talks seem to
Dennett so if anybody else in the
audience is looking for advice a couple
of announcements tonight one is that as
you might have heard in the last the
last talk we did we have released all
how many years it has been 15 years now
just about of long now talks without a
password and standard-definition on our
website and we have released an iOS app
and iPad app that and web or Apple TV
app that you can use to watch them not
all of them are up there yet we're still
digitizing that format but about 50 or
60 are up in that format now so you can
now watch sitting on your couch the
other announcement is that on June 6th
was long now's 20th anniversary
and for all this time we have been
speaking at you and what we want to do
is something a little bit different
which is to have on October 4th on here
in San Francisco at Fort Mason in about
three different venues a member summit
where you can all come and all the
almost all the programming is going to
be you speaking to each other so we're
gonna we're working with Brady Forrest
the founder of ignite to do a whole
ignite series so we welcome submissions
from all of you members to to submit
five-minute talk subjects and we're
gonna curate you know 20 or 30 of those
five-minute talks as well as a bunch of
other content like that and I think
Andrews putting together our long short
film festival of the long shorts we've
been doing over the years and more so
we'd love to get submissions of that so
there's gonna be a lot of ways for all
of you to connect with each other
because we've we've always known that we
have an amazing membership and we've
always been trying to figure out the
right ways to connect you all so this
will be our attempt we'll do it once
every 20 years and so hopefully we'll
see how it works out
so that anyway so save that date October
4th it'll be both a daytime programming
and evening programming it'll go all the
way late from midday to late that night
and lastly I want to introduce our long
short for tonight there's a sometimes
it's really difficult to come up with
what the long short is going to be this
particular one really chose itself it's
a poem by our speaker that was made into
movie form about the subject that you're
going to hear so enjoy
in America redeye planes fly east from
Los Angeles to New York between sunset
and sunrise collapsing the night
the flights west from New York to Los
Angeles predominate during the day
stretching that open the mess of the
American air fleet leaps at the Sun West
as the Sun heads west and east as the
Sun beneath them and over Asia resets to
East again northern birds sloshed down
from the pole to the equator in the late
month while southern birds are sloshing
from the equator down to the south pole
for their spring we humans have made
with all our fires and all our fuels the
longitudinal version looking at the
Earth from above centering over the
North Pole watched night and day sweep
around see Figure one the planes winging
outer Skelly around the rim now fix the
line of dark against light steady and
let the land and water circle beneath it
watch figure 2 the plains and the
continual flow to sunrise from sunset
like too hands cupping the earth from
her sides
a friend of mine makes a hundred grand a
year optimizing the algorithms that
arrange flight plans
in contrast helianthus annuus doesn't
know twists its floor it's in the
Fibonacci sequence our economy bristles
with efficiency with individual wills
building and buying collaborating and
competing by the millions but from the
longview injustice base just as elegant
a field of some flower buds craning for
light
[Music]
[Music]
Jeff's jet planes always sound like the
sky inhaling being this guy tonight
special night it is full moon coincident
with summer solstice that hasn't
happened for I think 70 years or so and
the long now they're quite frequent I'm
Stuart brand for the long now foundation
the next speaker is Kevin Kelly and
he'll be over here at their herbes first
time in a while since they reopened it
and he's been saying for a while he'll
be talking about the next 30 digital
years he's been saying for a while he
thinks that computers are in the process
of teaching us what it means to be human
and lately I've come across some of the
people that are working on that
algorithms that will accompany
self-driving cars and I suspect the
computers are going to teach us how to
be moral with great precision and indeed
it turns out computers are also teaching
us how to be smart and how to decide
well with great precision and for you
life hackers the guy with the golden
deck of advice is Bryan Christian
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart and Thank You sander
and thanks to the long now foundation
[Music]
the example that I would like to begin
with is one that is particularly and I
might say painfully familiar to those of
us who live in the Bay Area which is the
search for housing
now we typically have this idea that
being a rational consumer means having
an array of options considering all of
them ruminating about the one that you
like the best and then selecting that in
a sufficiently competitive marketplace
that's simply not possible as anyone who
has looked for an apartment in the Bay
Area knows open houses are mobbed and
the keys often end up in the hands of
whoever can physically voice the deposit
check on the landlord first now such a
savage market leaves little room for the
kind of fact-finding and deliberation
that's supposed to characterize this
kind of a process instead what we're
left with is a situation in which we
must make a binding commitment either
way as soon as we see the place either
we put our deposit in and we take it and
we never know what else is out there or
we walk away to gather more information
knowing that that opportunity is gone
and someone else has gotten it so what
do you do how do you try to make an
informed decision where when the very
act of informing yourself might cost you
potentially your very best opportunity
it is a it is a cruel situation
bordering almost on paradox fortunately
there's an answer and the answer is 37%
if you want the very best odds of
getting the very best apartment spend
exactly 37 percent of your search or one
ovary for the more mathematically
inclined in the audience noncommittally
yeah I'm glad I'm glad to you gets a
gets a clap that's good
spend 37 percent the first 37 percent of
your search so if you're given your
yourself a month to find a place the
first 11 days noncommittally exploring
your options you can leave your
checkbook at home you are just purely
calibrating after that point
be prepared to commit deposit and all to
the very first place you see that is
better than what you saw in the first 37
percent this is not merely an
intuitively satisfying compromise
between looking and leaping this is the
provably optimal results and we know
this because apartment hunting
especially in a competitive marketplace
like San Francisco as an example of what
computer scientists and mathematicians
know as an optimal stopping problem and
a an optimal stopping problem describes
any situation in life where we face this
structure of a decision where we have a
sequence of opportunities that come one
after another in sequence and at each
point we either have to commit and go
all-in or walk away and lose that
opportunity forever some people have
argued that this structure not only
describes their search for real estate
but also our search for love where when
you're in a relationship with someone
you at some point face the decision of
am I going all-in or am i walking away
and if you walk away you potentially
fourth with the ability to change your
mind later so you might be so bold as to
say well I'm just going to apply the 37%
rule directly to my romantic life to
find an interval over which you want to
find the right person calculate 1 over E
with 37% of that range
and know that this is the exact point at
which to make the shift from your dating
life being just for fun to things
starting to get serious of course it all
depends on the assumptions you're
willing to make about love the thesis of
of the work that I'm going to talk about
tonight and this book which is a
collaboration with my longtime friend
and UC Berkeley cognitive scientist Tom
Griffiths is very simple there's a set
of problems that all of us face in
everyday life as a function of having
finite space and finite time and finite
information whether it's looking for a
house or a partner or deciding where to
go out to eat or deciding how to deal
with our overflowing closet or how to
how to manage our time we think of these
things as being innately and uniquely
human problems they're not they in fact
correspond to a set of some of the most
fundamental problems studied by computer
scientists over the last 50 60 years or
more and this gives us a real
opportunity to learn something about how
to make better decisions in our own
lives by looking at what those problems
look like and the characteristics of
their solutions the book follows this
line of thinking into twelve different
domains and we're going to talk about
two of them tonight in greater detail
and I'll give a sort of a thumbnail
overview of the rest and the first are
optimal stopping problems now the 37%
rule comes from the perhaps most famous
optimal stopping problem which is known
as the secretary problem um it was first
popularized by Martin Gardner
in his column in Scientific American in
1960 and true to 1960 style it has this
very Mad Men flavor of you the implicit
male second person are hiring and
implicitly female secretary and
candidates show up in random order at
each moment you interview one and must
either hire her and send everyone else
packing or send her away and
interview the next candidate but she
never comes back so it was popularized
and kind of entered into the American
Mathematical imagination in the 60s but
the problem itself goes back to 1949
which was the first known public
presentation of this problem by this guy
merrill flood and it seems that flood
had its romantic implications in mind
even from the very beginning you see
flood was giving a presentation at a
mathematics conference at Princeton and
the minutes of this conference were
being taken by floods daughter who was
18 years old at the time and had just
started dating a much older man flood
and his wife strongly disapproved and
they hope that this relationship would
end quickly and so to kind of implicitly
give the message flood presents the
secretary problem and this is many years
before the solution was known but he
hoped that his daughter who was taking
the minutes would would get the hint
that the solution was probably more than
one
fortunately the relationship was indeed
short-lived the book tells some
cautionary tales of scientists and
mathematicians applying this sort of
logic directly to their love lives with
I think it's fair to say mixed results
one of my favorite stories is that of
Carnegie Mellon professor of operations
Research Michael Trick who was in a
relationship
as a graduate student asking himself
this question of how do I know if I'm in
the right relationship and all of a
sudden it dawns on him oh my god dating
of course it's an optimal stopping
problem and Here I am I'm an Operations
researcher I'm just gonna run the
numbers and so he ran the numbers and he
found 26.1 as the age after which to be
able to commit to the next person that
you meet who's better than all the
people you've already been dating he was
in a relationship at the time and so he
knew exactly what to do he proposed on
the spot and she shot him down
now trick faced what mathematicians who
study this problem know as rejection and
as it turns out you can make a simple
modification to the 37 percent rule to
account for the possibility that the
person might say no so if for example
there is a 50 percent chance of getting
rejected then the stopping threshold
moves to 25 percent you should be
willing to make an offer only 25% of the
way into the pool and if it doesn't work
just try again so so the the
mathematical wisdom here is proposed
early and often the other side of the
coin is represented I think best by the
famous astronomer Johannes Kepler who
after the death of his first wife went
on an epic and seemingly endless series
of court ships to try to find the
perfect person to to marry he was really
interested and we have access to
Kepler's diary and his letters which are
kind of staggeringly candid about all of
this he was really interested in the
fourth woman that he dated because of
her tall build an athletic body but he
was even more interested in number 5
because she really got along really well
with with her prospective stepchildren
but nonetheless he persevered and
continued dating over many years
ultimately a total of 11 different women
before having one of these sinking
realizations of like I've made a huge
mistake and realizing that he was number
five all along what was he thinking so
he hops a train to Regensburg gets down
on one knee apologizes for dating a half
a dozen other people and asks her
hopefully you're not you know promised
to someone else at this point maybe
you'll take me back and fortunately for
Kepler she does and the rest of their
lives are very happy together
now Kepler faced what's known in the
field as recall so this is the ability
to return to a candidate once you have
dismissed them and still have a chance
of getting them back
in his letters Kepler really beats
himself up for continuing to date people
after he met this amazing woman number
five and he he D cries what he calls his
restlessness and doubtfulness if why did
I continue with this futile search and
and leave this amazing person behind
well it may give Kepler or some peace of
mind but not his second wife that when
you have the ability to recall past
candidates restlessness and doubtfulness
are indeed part of the ideal optimal
solution and you should not make any
offer until you're at least 61 percent
of the way through the pool and only
then if you fail to meet anyone better
than someone from the first 61 percent
then you hop on the train to Regensburg
and try to try to make it right now
optimal stopping covers a lot more
problems like the then simply the the
dating and housing scenario and one of
the other ones which is also I would say
acutely and painfully familiar to San
Franciscans is the question of when to
park so we've all had this experience of
you know approaching some venue and you
know you're you're trying to hold out
for the best space and you see an
opening and you think to yourself there
might be a better spot
but if I keep going the next person
behind me is surely going to take it and
even if I swing back around it's gone
and so you may want to we include this
figure in the book you can cut it out
and put it on your dashboard so to an
optimal stopping theorists it all
depends on what's called the occupancy
rate which is what percentage of the
spaces are filled in that in that
particular neighborhood and so depending
on the occupancy rate there is a
specific number of spots away that you
should wait and then take the next
available spot so in a neighborhood
that's 90% full holed out into you are
seven spaces away which is about one
block if it's 99 percent full then you
should be willing to take the first
available space 69 spaces away which is
about a quarter of a mile if it's 99.99%
full I would not drive at all
and actually this is this is an
interesting case we're looking at the
optimal strategies for drivers not only
gives us a way to make better decisions
when we're behind the wheel but in this
case it also gives us some insight into
the urban planning problem of parking so
the the kind of traditional and typical
way of thinking about parking was that
it's simply a question of we have this
resource public spaces we want to
allocate them maximally to the maximum
number of cars but if you look here
going from a 90 to a 99 percent
occupancy rate only accommodates nine
percent more cars but it involves every
single driver driving ten times as far
to find a space and walking ten times as
far to the destination so more
contemporary urban planners kind of
inspired by some of these ideas have had
begun working with city governments to
push for lower occupancy rate in in
downtown urban areas which means raising
prices and one of the parking gurus
behind this ideas in the abdominal soup
at from UCLA and one of the first
instances of this is through SF Park
here in San Francisco when I interviewed
Donald Shoop that you know arguably the
world's expert on how to park what his
own research had taught him about his
how to optimize his commute to UCLA he
said yes I ride my bike
one of the things I think is really
interesting just in any domain there's
this irresistible question which is do
people innately actually implement the
optimal strategies or do we do dumb
things and when researchers have tested
optimal stopping problems in the lab
they find something very consistent
which is the the optimal rule and a
classic secretary problem is 37% lab
subjects implement a 31% rule that is
they have mostly the right idea but they
consistently start to commit too soon
now there are any number of XA so you
could sort of think about this maybe
we're we're loss averse that's a classic
example I think one of the most
interesting nuances here is that someone
looked at the data and said well you
know that the stopping rule that humans
are using is optimal if we were to
assign a one percent penalty to the to
their utility for each option they look
at and you know their their fellow
researcher said okay well that's weird
because there is no penalty for taking
more time and then of course they
realized of course there's a penalty for
taking more time these are laboratory
subjects doing an extremely repetitive
and boring experiment there's always a
penalty for taking up more of someone's
time and this to me points to what I
think is one of the more profound ideas
about optimal stopping problems in
general which is that when time itself
has a cost then you need to find a point
in any decision-making process when it's
not worth it to continue thinking to
continue gathering information and so
given that we are all just intrinsically
as human being subject to this cost of
time passing every decision-making
process becomes a question of when to
stop
now optimal stopping covers some of our
the largest decisions that we make in
life whether it's housing spouse's jobs
these sorts of things but one of the
most prevalent decisions that we make is
one that's iterated over and over and
over in the course of a day perhaps so
many times that we don't even realize it
and specifically it's a decision that
takes the form of a tension between
doing our favorite things and trying new
things so specifically you know you want
to go to eat do you go to your favorite
restaurant or do you try a new place
that just opened up and has gotten some
good reviews on the way there do you
listen to a classic cherish album or do
you try to discover some new music that
you might enjoy and who do you take to
dinner do you go with your spouse or
your close family or your your closest
circle of friends or do you reach out to
the co-worker who is new to the office
or an acquaintance that you'd like to
get to know better this is a case where
we intuitively understand that a life
well-lived is some kind of balance
between doing the things that we know
and love while staying open to new
possibilities of course that intuition
does not tell us what that balance
should be and fortunately computer
scientists have been trying to find this
exact balance for now almost a century
and they even have a name for it they
call it the Explorer exploit trade-off
so in this context exploring means
spending your energy gathering new
information exploiting which two
computer scientists doesn't have the
negative connotation that it does in
ordinary English just means spending
your energy leveraging the information
you've gathered to get a known good
result and so this comes up with in
computer science notably in the
optimization of ads so here I'm perhaps
do not have to explain this to this
particular crowd we have Google search
results with some ads highlighted in red
Google makes I think something like 95
percent of their revenue from selling ad
space and for any given search keyword
in this in this case there is a huge
pool of ads and specifically there is
the ad or set of ads that has gotten the
best historical track record of getting
clicks and there is any number of other
ads that they simply don't have as much
information about either they haven't
tried them as much or they're new to the
system or whatever and so here this
tension between going with the known
good thing and trying something new
becomes extreme
we explicit and quantified you can ask
the question of literally what
percentage of users should see the ad
that has the best track record for
getting clicks which percentage of users
should see new things that we want to
get more information about that could be
better there probably not but maybe they
could be ideas and strategies that have
been honed over many years of working on
problems like this within the computer
science community in the tech world are
just now starting to make their way into
the field of medicine so here to
illustrate the idea of clinical trials
we have Morpheus and if you think about
it a clinical trial has much the same
structure where for any particular
diagnosis or condition there is some
known best treatment and there's any
number of other experimental new
treatments that could be better and
could be worse and so as I will explain
some of the the key concepts from the
computer science work are now making
their way into the FDA how does the
computer scientists think about the
explore exploit trade-off the canonical
problem in the literature is called the
multi-armed bandit problem it's a pretty
strange name but it comes from the idea
of the slot machine as the one-armed
bandit and so a multi-armed bandit is
just a roomful of slot machines so
imagine you walk into a casino it's full
of these slot machines they each payout
at a different frequency some machines
are better than others but you just have
no idea which of course until you try
them and so quite simply let's say
you're going to be there for the
afternoon you know you have enough time
to pull 100 levers what strategy gives
you the best chance of walking away with
the most money well for most of the 20th
century this was considered not only an
unsolved problem but an unsolvable
problem and mathematicians during World
War two British mathematicians joked
about dropping the multi-armed bandit
problem over Germany as the the ultimate
instrument of intellectual sabotage just
to waste the brain power of the German
mathematician
so to make make some of this may quite
such a thorny problem a little bit more
explicit let's imagine you walk into a
casino that just has two machines one
you've played fifteen times nine times
it paid out six times it did not the
other machine you've tried just twice
once it paid out once it did not so what
do you do next
which handle do you pull now the most
straightforward way of addressing this
problem is to compute what's called the
expected value which is just what
percentage of the time as it paid out so
in this case it would be 60% in this
case 50% and so the you know the natural
thing is just to say well okay I'll just
pull the handle that has the best track
record but again there's a sense in
which this 1:1 machine we just don't
have enough information to kind of write
it off for good and again this was
considered basically you know in the
category of kind of brain teaser slash
you know career suicide because this
just wasn't really considered to be the
kind of thing that had an answer but
over the years a series of breakthroughs
starting with this guy Richard bellman
in the late 50s and continuing with John
Gittens in 1970s and so forth up till
today there have been a series of
substantial breakthroughs on the problem
and I think the the critical thing about
this question of which of these two
machines to pull is that it all comes
down to something that we haven't
explicitly talked about yet which is how
long you plan to be in the casino now
Tom and I call this concept in the book
a that will be familiar to long now
members we call it the interval and a
way to think about it is you know
imagine you've you've moved to Spain for
a year for work or something the first
restaurant you go to on your very first
night in Spain is literally guaranteed
to be the greatest restaurant you have
ever been to in Spain the second night
you say this is amazing I'm gonna go to
another place it's got a 50% chance of
being the greatest restaurant you've
ever been to in Spain night three you're
down to one and three that's still
pretty good but of course this goes down
as
your experience allows you to set a
higher bar and so the odds of making a
great new discovery that kind of
dethrones your pre-existing favorite
goes down as a function of your
experience the other key thing here to
note is that the value of of making
great new discovery also goes down as
you run out of time to enjoy it so if
you happen to find this incredible
charming place on your final night in
Spain it actually is kind of tragic
because you think yourself well geez I
wish I'd have known about this you know
eight or nine months ago that would've
been great and so naturally our
decision-making should shift as a
function of where we perceive ourselves
to be within the relevant interval of
time over which we're making the
decision now thinking in these terms has
for me completely changed the way that I
think about one of my favorite movies
the inspirational 1989 classic Dead
Poets Society and which has Robin
Williams as poetry professor John
Keating saying these inspirational
soliloquy is like seize the day boys
make your lives extraordinary and armed
with the knowledge of the Explorer
exploit right off we should cry foul
here because Robin Williams is in fact
giving two contradictory pieces of
advice if we just want to seize the day
we should pull that machine with the
higher expected value but if we want to
make our lives extraordinary then surely
it's worth pulling the handle of that
one one machine at least one more time
because if it is in fact better we have
the rest of our life to enjoy it and if
it's not we have the rest of our life to
do the other thing some of these ideas
have begun moving out of the field of
computer science and starting to
influence some of the sibling kindred
fields and for me one of the most
interesting is the field of psychology
and cognitive science where the idea
that our our strategy should change
relative to the interval that we're on
is influencing how developmental
psychologists and
cognitive scientists think about both
the early years in our life and the
later years in our life so to give us an
example of the early years this is an
infant that's plugging a power cable
into its face we have a lot of
stereotypes about babies
and-and-and young kids in general
they're kind of random they're generally
bad at things they have a really short
attention span they have a really
aggressive what's called novelty bias
there's a whole literature on how they
just like relentlessly prefer new things
to things that they already have no
matter how great their existing toys are
and so it's you know that it's tempting
to just think of them as inept versions
of adults but psychologists including
Alison Gopnik
here at UC Berkeley are appealing to
some of the ideas in the literature on
the explore exploit trade-off to make
the argument well no being random and
aggressively preferring new things is
exactly what you should do when you're
at the beginning of your entire life
you know if you've just burst through
the casino doors and you've got 80 years
to be there you really should just run
around pulling handles at random you
really should just put every single
object in your house into your mouth at
least once because it may be delicious
and you'll have 80 years to enjoy this
the explore exploit trade-off also I
think offers some pretty tantalizing way
of thinking about one of the other
strange things about the human species
which is that human infants and human
children are kind of uniquely useless
compared to other species so one of my
favorite facts on this is that an a
gazelle 3 hours after being born can
outrun a cheetah and escape being eaten
by a cheetah 95 with 95 percent success
humans are not I mean we're basically
useless for the first 20 years we aren't
allowed to operate heavy machinery
so what's up with this well the Explorer
exploit trade-off offers us at least one
I think pretty provocative way of making
sense of this idea and it's that when
your room and board is being taken care
of by your parents you are free to have
a purely exploratory beginning of your
life in a way that the Gazelle is not
that when when the moms and dads of the
world are buying your lunch you are not
dependent on those early jackpots in
order to just stay alive and so you can
enter into a more purely exploratory
phase which is probably exactly what you
should be doing it at the very beginning
of your life now at the other end of
life we have people in their later years
older adults and we likewise have a set
of kind of preconceived ideas and biases
about what the lives of older adults are
like you know we think they're that
they're very set in their ways they're
very resistant to change or resistant to
new ideas there's a lot of psychological
literature on this idea that they have
they maintain fewer and fewer social
connections and so it can be tempting to
regard this as like oh it must be just
lonely or something like this but again
sort of drawing on the intuitions of the
Explorer exploit trade-off researchers
like Stanford's Laura Carstensen are
making the argument that no no no no no
that's not what's going on at all older
adults are deliberately and aggressively
pruning their social lives down to the
people who actually matter and not
dealing with their flaky acquaintances
anymore because you know who cares and
that they have they have entered the
exploit phase of life where they are are
deliberately focusing on the things that
really matter most and are happier for
it now the the algorithms that get
computer scientists excited are what are
called minimal regret algorithms so in
the multi-armed bandit problem you can
quantify regret as the amount of money
that you could have made if only you had
known what you knew at the end at the
beginning which I think it's a pretty
satisfying way of quantifying the
concept
of regret and there's a family of
algorithms that offer what is called
minimal regret and specifically they
offer logarithmic regret and there's
good news and bad news I'll give you the
bad news first the bad news is you will
never stop making mistakes no matter how
well you learn and how optimal your
strategy is the good news is that your
mistakes will decrease in their severity
and frequency over time continually as
you go through life and I think I think
that's something we can all feel pretty
good about now the FDA has been looking
over the disciplinary fence at some of
these minimal regret algorithms for ways
of rethinking their approach to clinical
trials now the classic clinical trial is
just your sort of randomized controlled
trial we give 50% of these people this
thing 50% of these people the other
thing we pretty much just close our eyes
and let the study proceed except there's
kind of an ombudsman person who's there
with like a giant red button if
something totally goes off the rails but
otherwise we'll you know we'll look at
the end and see the information at the
end now this is itself an algorithm that
is known to computer scientists it's
called epsilon first and it's not known
to be a very good algorithm and it's
linear regret for example and so there
is this push within the medical
community and among biostatisticians and
computer scientists and so forth to use
some of the very same algorithms that
are already hard at work behind most
websites optimizing ads for situations
in which the stakes are in fact much
much higher and one of the arguments
that I've heard is you know how can you
just coldly appeal to some algorithm
when human lives are on the line and I
think an equally valid counter-argument
is how can you not use this strategy
that has you know a guaranteed minimal
regret when the stakes are that high so
it's extremely interesting to me these
these documents are from 2010 and 2015
so the FDA is literally as we speak
trying to think about how to how to
adopt some of these ideas and rethink
their approach to clinical trials and so
for me this is very significant because
you know thinking computationally about
this this fundamental human problem I
think offers us some some insights and
some rewards at a number of scales you
know we we can think differently about
where to go out to eat we it gives us a
way of thinking about kind of the arc of
human life and how our thinking does and
should change as a result of kind of
where we perceive ourselves to be not
only in terms of our lifespan but in any
of the other smaller intervals that
we're on in life and lastly it gives us
some I think surprisingly concrete
guidance in the cases where where the
stakes are really the highest so now I'm
gonna talk very briefly about some of
the other things that are on the book in
the book and which hopefully will have
an opportunity to get more or two in the
conversation so the book pursues this
kind of computational lens to to human
decisions and human problems over a
number of domains so the first half of
the book is really just following
tracking the different domains of things
in the sorting chapter we talk about the
best way to alphabetize your bookshelf
and more importantly whether you should
and sorting theory also gives a little
bit of consolation for sports fans on
cases where we should or should not
trust the outcome of a sorting procedure
in the chat chapter on caching we talk
about memory management and storage
management and specifically what can
computer science teach us both about how
to deal with our overflowing closet at
home and with the phenomenon of human
memory and humans forgetting more
generally in scheduling we look at
scheduling theory both as it arises in
the machine shops of the Industrial
Revolution on to the operating system
CPU schedulers of today and we basically
ask the question of what if anything
have we learned about human
procrastination and human time
management from several decades of
fighting the the interminable beachball
of death
what causes that what do we do to make
it stop and what can we learn from this
the chapter on Bayes rule gets into the
computer science of how to make good
predictions about the future and this is
something that I think is particularly
relevant to long now members and
especially to people who traffic on long
bets which is a wonderful website so if
you want to make accurate predictions
about the future it turns out that one
of the absolutely simplest but in some
ways surprisingly accurate algorithms
it's called the Copernican principle
which just says that you should always
assume something is going to last twice
as long as it's lasted so far which is
which given certain bounds is is
actually a quite a reasonable heuristic
and so we include predictions for like
you know Google will probably last until
2030 to the United States will last
until like the mid 23rd century and if
you're if you've met someone on
Valentine's Day and you're trying to
decide is it is it premature to book New
Year's Eve tickets the answer is yes and
when is it not premature to book New
Year's Eve tickets
the answer is Saturday July 23rd the
second half of the book builds an
argument for what we call computational
kindness which is a way for for applying
some of these principles and some of
these insights into thinking more
societally about how we interact with
each other both interpersonally but also
you know as a policy question how can we
design a world that is computationally
kinder to us that that presents us with
easier problems to solve and it also
looks at cases where what does computer
science tell us about problems where
there is no simple straightforward
optimal algorithm and this to me is
extremely interesting because I think it
gives us an opportunity to rethink our
notion of what rationality itself is and
so I'll just say a few words about this
so we have this intuition that being
rational is about being exhaustive you
know considering all your options
thinking everything through to the end
being deterministic following a policy
that's guaranteed to work every time
that's going to
same result reliably every time and is
exact it gives you an answer that is
both highly precise and with a high
degree of certainty that it is the
answer and looking at the computer
science of dealing with so-called
intractable problems or np-hard problems
shows us that up against the hardest
classes of problems computers do none of
these things they are not exhausted they
explore a limited subset of their of
their possible options and they trade
off the costs of making an error against
the cost of delay um they're not
deterministic they use randomness they
follow procedures that are not
guaranteed to produce the same answer
reliably and they're in exact they use
approximations they use trade-offs they
produce answers with partial degrees of
certainty so one of my absolute favorite
examples of this is in encryption which
is of course essential to you know
everything from military to banking to
online shopping everything encryption on
the web begins with generating huge
prime numbers and so there is
mathematicians and earlier in the 20th
century boasted about how useless the
study of prime numbers was until all of
a sudden it became extremely important
to national security and all these
things so there's there's an intense
value in good algorithms for determining
whether a number is prime and it turns
out that the one that we currently use
is wrong 25 percent of the time and
we've just decided that's okay we'll
just run it a few times and it's
probably going to cancel out over time
so I interviewed some of the
implementers for example of open SSL and
I said well how many Miller Rabine tests
do you guys run he said that 40 is
probably good enough this gives us a 1
over 4 to the 40 chance of making an
error and that's like one in a million
million billion and you know that's okay
so even at the highest level computers
don't necessarily adhere to these things
that we stereotypically think of
computers is doing and out of that I
would say emerges a different way of
thinking about rationality and a series
of principles and pieces of advice that
that don't necessarily look like we
might what we
expect to get from computer science they
say things like don't consider all your
options don't necessarily go for the
thing that's best every time make a mess
on occasion travel light let things wait
trust your instincts and don't think too
long relax and toss a coin and unlike
the principles that you might find for
example in a typical self-help book
they're backed by proofs Thanks
[Applause]
my leg went to sleep the last one on
there I love you said something about
computational kindness what's that yeah
mm-hmm
the basic idea of computational kindness
is that the way that we interact with
other people both explicitly and
implicitly poses them problems to solve
and so you can you can from this
argument make a bridge from computer
science into ethics and say that we
ought to interact with people in a way
that minimizes the computational cost
and so I would say out of this I'll give
you a very explicit example so I've just
started looking at the real estate
market and the real estate market drives
me nuts but perhaps not for the reasons
that it drives most people nuts it
drives me nuts because it's
computationally unkind and that it
requires you to do more strategizing
than is necessary
so homes are sold by a single price
auctions where everyone writes down
their bid the person who writes the big
biggest bid wins and they win at the
price they wrote down and so it creates
this incentive to get inside the head of
your competitors figure out how many
other people are bidding on the house
and what's called shade your bid which
is figure out the maximum price you'd be
willing to pay and figure out the
appropriate amount less than that to bid
such that you still win the house but
you save money and it just requires an
awful lot of strategy you want to try to
suss out how many other people are in
the auction what do they think I think
they think and so forth and it turns out
this is all completely unnecessary
there's this really wonderful mechanism
that's called a Vickrey auction where
everyone writes down their bid and the
person with the highest bid wins but
they pay the price of the second highest
bid and it turns out that the Vickrey
auction is what is called into game
theorists strategy proof which is
there's absolutely no better way to play
the game than to just write down your
exact evaluation of the house the game
optimizes for
you and so that to me is a really it's a
specific example but I think it's a
powerful example of this broader theme
which is you know in game theory it's
this is called the revelation principle
it's that any auction that involves this
sort of recursive I'm trying to get into
your head
process can be replaced with an auction
that has different rules in which the
best thing that you can possibly do is
just be totally honest and the house
will go to the same person for the same
price on average as in the strategic
version so that to me gives me this
almost utopian view that there are these
opportunities this kind of low-hanging
fruit to to change the role in ways to
just eliminate these costs clarifying
algorithms like that that might apply to
voting politically yeah I mean voting is
a great example so the word strategic is
a negative is a pejorative term to a
computer scientist or game theorist one
strategic behavior tactical wins or what
are we saying in in game theory and and
what's called mechanism design strategic
behavior is anything other than doing
what you really think and so if I you
know if we imagine the you know the the
nadir Gore election or whatever maybe
I'm a Green Party supporter but I vote
for Gore anyway because I don't want to
throw the election that's strategic
behavior I'm not I'm not doing what I
really think and so there are mechanisms
for voting like Instant Runoff voting
ranked preferences mmm-hmm but there are
some disheartening results in the
literature that say that there basically
is no completely strategy proof voting
mechanism there is a strategy proof
auction mechanism but there's not a
strategy proof voting mechanism but I
still think it's therefore I mean what
is it that mean that leaves us with a
failed system yeah okay so what well
what's the algorithm for dealing with
the field I'm not an expert on voting
theory but my understanding is that for
every possible voting mechanism you can
imagine some sort of horrible pernicious
condition but the current voting system
is one in which we are already seeing
the bad pernicious condition in evidence
and so we might as well try something
else at least for a while and say that's
better I have two questions one from
Barry Gordon one from Wayne very Gordon
wondered if you use an algorithm to
decide when to stop working on this talk
or the book by the way Wayne - did you
apply optimal stopping and choosing your
fiancee did she apply it and choosing
you oh do you use this stuff yeah yeah I
do
um my fiancee Rose claims that I told
her at some point that 37 percent of the
average American male lifespan was
something like 29 and you know we were
dating at the time and I was 29 side
apparently I said something like so if
this if this works I'm all-in which I
was it did and I was but I don't it's it
sounds like the kind of thing I would
say but I don't remember saying that I
mean I think I will say this you know
the the the language of exploration and
exploitation has literally become the
way that I talk about these sorts of
choices so you know my fiancee Rose and
I will will decide you know do you feel
like exploiting or exploring tonight
that is that is actually how we have
these conversations and sort of giving
it that generic framing does that help
the discussion and help you get moved
quickly drew decision of a new
restaurant or not yeah it does and you
know so we were assuming that I would be
moving into her place in Oakland and so
this this gave us a very clear directive
which is that we should exclusively go
to our favorite places in San Francisco
and relentlessly try new places in
Oakland even though they're probably not
as good as our favorite places because
we have you know this whole new time
opening up but the plot twist was that
we change our minds and she's in fact
moving in with me in San Francisco and
so it was like 180
let's aggressively go to new restaurants
in San Francisco and only go to our
favorite restaurants in Oakland pretty
smart
did some asks what was your recess
research process and path for actually
researching the book and I'm guessing
that this book grew art of the previous
book which was called the most human
human and it was about AI basically yeah
yeah it was about my participation and
what was the sequence of events for you
leading from book 1 to book two
yeah ironically I have been working on
this book since before I even wrote my
previous book I thought that this would
be my first book but I what the hell
happened I got wrapped up in this crazy
adventure participating as what's called
a human Confederate in a Turing test
competition which I'm sure many people
in the audience know but for those who
don't Alan Turing had this idea in 1950
he's asking these philosophical
questions you know can machines think
could we build a machine that could
think and if so how would we know and
his idea was we'll just have a test
we'll have a contest we'll stick a panel
of scientists into a bunch of chat rooms
they'll be talking simultaneously with
some random humans hidden in a room down
the hall and some software programs
claiming to be random humans in a room
down the hall and that we will reach a
point at which we can't tell the
difference and so I I kind of insinuated
myself into the history of this by
becoming one of the humans hidden in the
room down the hall but I was something
of a ringer because I had spent the
previous year researching the history of
the Turing test and interviewing all
that all the possible experts you or the
far from a random you I was far from a
random human yeah and were you trying to
pretend to be a computer or what no it
is it is my job to persuade the judges
that I am in fact a real person not a
computer claiming to be despite the fact
that the heart is using the same exact
thing was certain hmm this is an
interesting trick the Turing test how do
you persuade a human or human not a
computer which is their method that that
is the question that obsessed me for the
years that I was working on this so how
do you try to act human in a competitive
situation
and and to make matters even more
intriguing so the contest every judge
assigns a numerical score to each
conversation which is how confident they
were they were talking to a real person
and every year a computer program gets
the highest score and wins this it gets
high score among the other computer
programs and wins this thing called the
most human computer award you get a
bronze medal and three grand so it's
very nice but there's also every year a
real person that gets the highest score
among all of the real people as having
most successfully persuaded the judges
that they were human compared to the
other humans and you if you get this you
are awarded what's called the most human
human title for the year and so I found
myself kind of despite myself not only
competing against the computers but in
fact competing against the other real
people how'd you do
that's the spoiler the books been out
long enough that I'll proudly say that I
won the title of most human human so
that book was researched and written win
mmm it came out in 2011 so that I was
working on that from like late Oh a to
2011
okay we're 2016 now and still counting
and the conversation the public
discourse about ai's seems to be moving
right along what have you noticed from
then to now oh yeah
right so this this book came out in the
spring of 2011 which was pre Siri
and just to give you an idea of how long
ago that really was and the thing that's
really striking to me I remember going
out on the hardcover book tour in the
spring of 2011 and the the number one
most popular question I was getting
asked at the time was do you think AI
will take over my job on the paperback
tour a year later the number one
question was do you think AI will take
over the world
the destructive way in it yeah yeah yeah
just burn everything to the ground and
so that for me was it was just a really
striking I mean I really think over the
the last several years which is not that
of a time this has gone from a
completely sort of loony-bin sci-fi
thing like some of the best scientific
minds here in here in San Francisco the
open AI Institute some of some of the
most respected computer science
researchers people that I enormously
admire are taking this from extremely
seriously and so as a result I myself
have been converted from from a skeptic
thinking this is all a bunch of you know
sci-fi hogwash I'd read about the
existential issue yeah like we we
actually do need to be tuned you are
worried I'm concerned because in my view
the the scenarios that are bad resemble
very closely the reasons that the world
is already bad so one of the one of the
big problem is for change in AI is
defining what's called a good objective
function which is how do you formalize
the thing that we want the system to do
in a way that won't make us sorry for
what we wish for I would assume what you
want to formalizes things you don't want
the system to do and then explore
otherwise okay
the typical model is that you define
sort of a reward function for things you
think are good and inevitably you
discover some horrible externality that
you forgot to build into the system when
you want to do is work from what are the
sides of the road drive on and who cares
where the road goes yeah that may be
yeah that may be so I think this is this
is this is an open problem so yeah the
more people thinking about this the
better and I see it as significant
because I think it's what's already
wrong with the world that we we have
defined various objective functions
whether it's you know quarterly earnings
or GDP or whatever that we we take to be
approximate correlates of human
flourishing but we have optimized them
at our peril and created these huge
externalities so this is why this is for
me kind of the awakening moment at which
I realized that a lot of these hey I
said there's this AI thought experiment
called the paperclip Maximizer is you
know what the paper Nick Bostrom came up
with them yeah yeah yeah right what if a
paperclip factory invents a
and it turns the entire galaxy into
paperclips I'm not worried about that
scenario but I but I'm worried about the
genre of things that involve this kind
of like we've created this objective
function and we've relentlessly
maximized we're on the way maximising
thing so is the discussion which by 2012
was about other going to end the world
to stop there or is AI discussion moving
on since then I think the the question
of will a I take my job has also kind of
evolved into will a I take every job and
so for me this is another interesting
thing where ideas like universal basic
income have like gained track I would I
would argue have gained a foothold
culturally by starting with the people
who are really credible about AI saying
we've got to think about sort of a post
jobs economy and you know to my to my
point of view over the last couple years
have started to kind of percolate into
mainstream society starting with you
know the computer scientists and the AI
people Jill tarter asks how do we or
should we deal with existential problems
unintended or unknowable consequences in
the far future oh you know we're we're
an interplanetary now I think one of the
one of the chapters in the book talks
about this idea for machine learning
that's called overfitting the basic idea
here I mean it's a similar to what we
were saying before so in a sense we're
talking about an interval which is sort
of infinite yeah I mean there's so
there's a couple ways to come at this
question so in an explore exploit
context you can ask this question of
okay if my strategy is supposed to
depend on the integral that I'm on how
do I try to optimize for the infinite
indefinite future that would be there so
called
infinite game where you're always
improving the game for millennia after
millennium
yeah yeah and so there you may be
relieved to know that the infinite but
geometrically discounted future reward
version of the multi-armed bandit
problem was solved in the 1970s by John
Ginza
at Oxford who at the time was this is to
me is sort of an interesting aside he
was academic mathematician but he been
hired as a consultant to the Unilever
Corporation who wanted to know what
percentage of our budget should go into
speculative R&D versus just marketing
profitable drugs and so corporations are
interesting examples of something
well that's classic explore exploit
isn't it yeah exactly
and it all kind of depends on the
horizon that they feel they're operating
on and so I think corporations nations
and institutions are examples of these
things that prioritize present survival
obviously but aspire to be indefinite
and so some of the algorithms that come
out of the infinite horizon version of
the problem are very interesting to me
in global business Network which taught
scenario planning we ran into a version
of this problem which is that very large
corporations need to do scenario
planning because basically they're
looking at and government departments
and so on they're looking at a very long
time frame but it's absolutely worthless
for a start-up to do scenario planning
because the startup is making a bet on a
version of the world that they think is
probably true yeah and their innocence
totally RnB and so you know having
multiple ways the world might go is not
that useful to them because they're in
pure discover what's going on adapt
pivot all that kind of stuff there in a
very short timeframe yeah I mean there's
this really interesting result that in
in machine learning there's this idea
called regularization which is that it's
kind of the formal version of Occam's
razor it's that like if you have a bunch
of different models that all give you a
pretty good prediction take the simplest
model the one with the fewest knobs on
it the fewest parameters and I think
this is very interesting when it comes
to long-term planning because one of the
ideas here is that you know you you
train every model on the the data
available to you at the present but
you're trying to generalize it into the
future and so the farther into the
future you generalize it the more you
should regularize your model that is the
simpler it should be the fewer
parameters that it should be and so
what I kind of take this to mean is that
if you're if you're trying to predict
you know the state of the economy or the
market next year you want elaborate
models but if you're trying to if you're
trying to make really long-term thinking
then principles serve better than models
you know things with the fewest
parameters yeah we comes guidelines
along now it's a similar kind of idea
Damon asks what can algorithm has
learned from neuroscience around human
decisions and you're also getting into
you things like Danny Kahneman the
system one system to intuition versus
you know serious study and the
behavioral economists who are looking at
these things
how do those fields relate um I can't
speak with a great authority about
neuroscience but but one of the things
that for me is really fascinating about
the human brain from a neuroscience
standpoint is that if you think of a
brain as being kind of like an
organization the larger it is the more
discombobulated it can become Society of
mind Marvin Minsky says yeah yeah I mean
so literally the more volume the brain
takes up the more potentially out of
sync you know the computation can become
because it's you've got this latency
between the hemispheres and so forth and
so there's this really interesting
anatomical study that talks about like
the so for electrical reasons that I
don't fully understand thicker axons can
transmit signal more rapidly across a
long distance so you see this if you if
you look at mammal brains the thickness
of the inter hemispheric axons scales
with the volume of the brain because you
need to move signals faster from one
hemisphere to the other because they're
just further away but the trade-off is
that you're less volumetrically
efficient because you have these huge
pipes and so if you plot all mammal
brains on a curve you get one outlier
which is humans and specifically we're
an outlier in that we do not have as
thick of axons as
you would expect given our brain volume
which means that our brains are more
volumetrically efficient they can do
more computation in that amount of space
at the risk of greater interim aspheric
lag so you know speaking to this kind of
decentralized self society of mine thing
our species has made a very particular
gambit which is that it's we have a more
powerful computing organ but it's it's
more out of sync with itself or out of
sync with itself is it also possibly
more general-purpose in some sense
servable I think so I mean I think this
kind of speaks to the the long period of
uselessness at the beginning of human
lives then that that my understanding
and it rings true to me is that that
goes hand in hand with the generality
that we're not we are not sort of single
purpose ochita evading machines but we
are these sort of general machines but
we know that's that's yes as we get to a
200 year lifespan instead of settling
down becoming an adult at 20 it'll be
more like 40 I think that's probably
true I suspect that's probably already
happening
[Applause]
let the record show the audience agreed
here's a question from Boris looks likes
MOS that can't be right
what aspects of computer science
thinking should not be adopted by humans
I think most of the history of computer
science has been characterized by an
assumption that the machinery is
reliable and if you assume that the
machinery is alive reliable then what
you want to do is maximize that wasn't
true for long enough computers were
funky and there was all the Chanin of
you know how do you get reliable stuff
from the you know unreliable yeah yes
signal and all of that are they reliable
now well I mean what's interesting is
that the machines themselves are I I
have to imagine many orders of magnitude
more reliable than you know the vacuum
tubes and so forth but the scale at
which we're doing computations is also
much greater so when you're talking
about like extremely large distributed
computations the chance that some freak
gamma ray comes in and flips a bit you
know at this exact moment or some
there's some sort of weird neutrino
burst that has some you know these these
completely freaked things start to have
nonzero you know occurrences and they
start to wreck your computation if you
redo the computation also see that in
genetics or just learned the other day
that the cold-adapted pigs in the
northern part of korea flipped one base
pair huh out of three and half billion
to get that capability that's cool right
so there's there's there's kind of a
renaissance within theoretical computer
science to care about what's called
robustness and so care about what's
called robustness mm-hm
so for example sorting algorithms the
the kind of punching-bag algorithm for
computer science students is called
bubble sort which sorts something by
looking for out of order pairs and then
just correcting them at this very micro
level and it's kind of famously
inefficient but if you're
our operation is unreliable then if you
make a mistake you've only made a
mistake of you know distance 1 whereas
these sort of famously lauded you know
linearithmic algorithms like merge sort
if you make a mistake in an emerge for
top eration you could end up in the
wrong half of the results and so this in
the book we talk about this in the
context of sports so you know March
Madness if your team loses the first
game you were just permanently relegated
to the bottom 32 teams even if you were
the second-best team in the whole
tournament it turns out there's there's
some really interesting work coming out
of the University of New Mexico right
now on robust sorting algorithms and the
the most robust quadratic or better
sorting algorithm known is what's called
comparison counting sort which is
effectively like a round-robin
tournament where each item is compared
to each other item and the traditional
view is that this sucks it's quadratic
you know whatever but it turns out to be
the single most robust algorithm known
against a noisy comparator function and
so this I think provides a little bit of
a double edged thing for sports fans
which is that if your team loses you
think inappropriately early in the post
in the in the merge sort postseason you
will get sympathy from a computer
scientist but if your team fails to
qualify for the postseason because their
comparison counting record in the
regular season is too bad you will not
get from a computer scientist that is a
robust results and we all crave that
approval from the computers on
so I'm curious if some things are
getting into a kind of a post
algorithmic world with deep learning and
things like that where they're very very
complex systems very distributed working
with vast amounts of data and mining and
astonishingly in inventive ways some of
them that we can't entirely track and
you're getting systems that can do
things that what's right but is there
really an algorithm in there that you
can say that yeah well done that's the
right algorithm or you know what are we
facing here yeah there's there's
something in my opinion uncomfortably
inscrutable about deep learning
specifically you know I some good
friends of mine work at Instagram and
Facebook on on some of their algorithms
for what to show you when and they there
is this kind of well we tried all this
crazy ml stuff machine learning stuff
and it outperforms the best you know old
school algorithms that we have but no
one knows how to how it actually works
and no one knows really how to debug it
using the traditional debugging methods
of you know track down the exact point
at which the the problem happened and I
suspect we will make strides in this
direction but it is a little bit
discomforting when someone tells you
yeah we've got this system and it's
better than anything any of our actual
staff can make and so that's why we're
using it but no one really knows how it
works that does that does start to sound
like the first step in permanently
inscrutable do you think yeah sorry it
does start to sound like the first five
minutes of a sci-fi b-movie yeah yeah
the next thing is consciousness and then
you're in trouble or not the first thing
it may say is I'm sorry
but that would have it having to
understand about the concept of apology
which is a deep one is that a permanent
condition or are we sort of seeing these
deep learning capabilities emerging from
a complex process we can't completely
parse but we can then ask the deep
learning process to please tell us in
terms we can understand yeah yeah yeah
what is your mechanism here I mean it to
me it's very interesting I feel like the
justice system the human justice system
works this way where if someone does
something bad but they can give you a
really compelling story about why they
took that action then it's somehow okay
and once these programs discover that
they can just take the easy way out
until us a compelling story
oh that's it and then we're yeah then
we're really and then we're dead meat
yeah so okay there's a sequence of
events from you started on this book
then you've veered into a I thing
discovered the human versus AI and AI
keeps moving and you're now I've done
this book do you get a sense of what the
arc is here their narrative is there
progress in your own sequence of events
here what's next yeah I mean they're for
me i'm i'm currently preoccupied with
three things one is this AI safety stuff
because i really yeah i mean i see it as
being to me it is interesting because i
mean my my like academic background was
as computer science and philosophy
double major and so i I sort of think of
each discipline in the terms of the
other and so for me what's interesting
about the AI ethics stuff is that it is
it is giving us an opportunity and by
that I mean you know possibly urgent
crisis to make headway on these long
standing ethical problems that have kind
of always been there right on that that
that now it's crunch time and we really
need to do something so that that to me
is exciting you know
conceptually in the way that I thought
thinking about the Turing test was
really interesting philosophically
because we've got this 2500 year long
history of philosophers asking what
makes humans unique and distinct and
special and going back to Aristotle
we've answered this question by
contrasting ourselves with animals and
so I see the development of the computer
in AI in particular it's kind of turning
2500 years of Western philosophy on its
head because we now ask the question of
how are we distinct from machines and so
I should I'm word of the animal yeah
yeah yeah and we're we're I think much
more feel much more kindred with animals
than we did before the computer that's
that's kind of sweet so are you looking
at this dangerous AI problem from the
sort of existential risk standpoint or
from the what do we do in the next
couple years of research standpoint I'm
interested in the question of how do we
articulate what it is that we really
want how do we create an objective
function that that actually does capture
the things that we have in mind when we
when we talk about say some sample
versions of that be an example I mean
there for me what's interesting about
this is that if you look at
utilitarianism there are a bunch of
these paradoxes and utilitarianism that
are called the repugnant conclusion and
the idea here is that like these very
simple naive ideas of like oh let's just
maximize total happiness across all
people that sounds great
well you know you may end up in a world
in which you've severely overpopulated
the earth and everyone is you know
infinitesimally happier than zero and
there's are so many people that that
your objective function tells you that's
a better world that's what you've asked
for sum total of all human happiness so
then you think okay that's not what I
really meant what
was the optimizing for the mean human
happiness and then you get these crazy
scenarios where there's like this cast
of permanently kind of indentured or
tortured people just just as long as
everyone else is
more made more happy than those people
are made miserable then this is the
world your best where you've optimized
from your okay you say well that's not
really what I meant and so for me I'm
you know again I I'm interested in like
the this sort of current cultural moment
with respect to AI because it gives us
it sort of puts these things in the
crosshairs in a way in which like these
utilitarian paradoxes have been
discussed in you know philosophy
departments and these white papers for X
number of decades and you know just like
it was with prime numbers you know
people studied prime numbers for a long
time and then they suddenly became
extremely useful and extremely important
and I think some of the similar some of
these similar things are happening in
utilitarianism where it's like some of
these paradoxes that seem to completely
abstract and just like mind games for
philosophy departments all of a sudden
now it's like wait a minute we actually
it's it's it's a big problem that we
can't define like the world that we want
yeah philosophical things like the
trolley problem or you know turning up
with these self-driving cars totally
stuff like that okay so you say looking
at AI hazards is one thing you're
focusing on what else yeah the other two
I'm interested in computational
linguistics so I think that there's
really an interesting we're the field of
computational linguistics is kind of
having a moment what's happened
I think it's it's a technology that's
coming into its own the idea of natural
language processing is now due in large
part to advance this just in computation
it's now a field that is kind of like
ripened in a way that I think is
teaching us again it's like what what is
our newest technology teaching us about
our oldest technology that to me is an
interesting question oldest technology
being like being
you know the word that may not literally
be the oldest but you know I four
rhetorical purposes it sounds like
there's a book Claire and what's your
glimmers of what you know this work on
computational linguistics is teaching us
about language in human I mean I think
it's I think it's changing our sense of
what a word is for example there was a
there's a Supreme Court ruling in 2011
there was this case that went to the FCC
where AT&T was asked to their 18 t was
subpoenaed by the FCC to provide some
document they did not want to provide
the document so this is in the wake of
the Citizens United ruling on corporate
personhood they said we're invoking our
right to personal privacy and this goes
to the Supreme Court and it becomes this
linguistic question of our all persons
entitled to personal rights personal
privacy and so forth and so what seems
like this this kind of corporate thing
actually becomes a linguistic ruling on
his personal the same word in as your
title form or is it a distinct word with
a distinct meaning and and we should
treat these as unrelated concepts and so
for to my knowledge the first time the
court has traditionally used the OED on
these things and trace the etymology and
say well in old sex in or whatever in
this case they turn to like big data
corpora studies saying okay let's just
ingest every New York Times article ever
you know every Wikipedia article ever
and we will run these sort of word cloud
things and see do people do humans use
the word person in the same contexts
that they use the word personal and the
the answer was no they don't they use
them in distinct ways thus the court
ruled that they are two different words
and not every person is entitled to
personal things
therefore AT&T had to cough up the
documents and the majority opinion ends
with the great zinger we trust that AT&T
will not take this personally
I'm tempted to end there but let's sound
like there was one more area that you're
you're focusing on what would that yeah
yeah so I'm really interested in what
I've been calling reproducible
journalism so it seems to me that this
this is sort of inverting my role so
rather than thinking as a writer about
computer science I'm thinking as a
computer scientist about writing great
so it strikes me you know whenever I see
you know read an article that'll say you
know the grid is now six percent
renewable or you know we're on track to
reach price parity of fossil fuels and
solar you know at year X or you know the
the police have shot X number of people
this year in the stone I this this thing
goes off in my brain which is like where
are you getting that you know I'm just
reading it's like it's like someone
giving you a time series and just giving
you a single data point and saying you
know here's the story and that's not the
story so it really seems to me like
there's an opportunity to kind of bring
bring journalism and and some of the
political the way that we make claims
about civic things into the 21st century
it seems like there's a really an
opportunity to do something there and
you see any of these things going toward
a Booker's you truly do yes it's I'm you
know if my previous experience is any
indication they will all happen but not
in the order that I think they're going
to have it
all right so you've got a book how
long's this book been out the came out
in and mid April late April so it's been
out there for a while they've been
touring a bit and you've dealt with
people dealing with it just say
something about what and he's a writer
one always wonders what are the people
gonna do with this thing yeah a bit over
for a couple years what are people doing
with your book that delights you and
puzzles you yeah I mean I I have to
think about the puzzles one I may not
yet know about the puzzling things
before well how about delights and
disturbs yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean it's
it's as you can tell from my manner when
I talk about these things there is a
there is an element of the book that is
completely an earnest and there's an
element of the book that's
tongue-in-cheek and so I'm you know we
Tom and I attempt to delineate these
things tonally I'm sure there are people
that are going to take the
tongue-in-cheek things extremely
literally to disastrous results you know
so for example if you if you read the
fine print on the 37 percent rule you
discover that it is optimised for a
particular objective which is giving you
the best chance of getting the best
thing
however it's it only succeeds 37% of the
time and so here's a case where even
following the opposite that's a failure
no bail sixty-three percent of the time
and so yeah I almost feel like the need
to put some kind of disclaimer like
we're not responsible for the 63 percent
of you who do this and it doesn't work
out are people coming in and say it
didn't work for me [ __ ] I mean that's
a great question I think over the years
we will probably get correspondence of
from people saying I did or did not
propose to my partner based on reading
this thing right and it either I there
have been a couple success stories where
people have said you know I've now made
this change after read
your book and thank you and and that
obviously makes me very pleased but I'm
sure there will be the reverse I'm sure
and but there's one other at least two
other audiences you're the philosophers
that you've hung out with these years
and the computer scientist you'd be
coming out with these years what are
those guys making this yeah I mean I
think the to me the book is able to kind
of bridge those Disciplinary communities
they want to be bridge those two that's
a good question yeah I think so I think
so I mean I for me it's interesting for
for non computer scientists the book is
kind of a gateway drug into computer
science great and for computer
scientists the book reveals the the
highly interdisciplinary nature of the
things that their comrades are working
on and discovering in a way that's not
necessarily obvious to people who are in
the trenches optimizing these things
that you know for example I know ton of
people that work in ad tech and so then
saying to them you know this is actually
kicking off potentially you know the
biggest change in in medical clinical
trial practice in 50 60 years the people
who are who are in the weeds don't
necessarily realize that that there are
these larger scale things and I think
it's very satisfying for both camps to
have an opportunity to to see the
connection between the two so that to me
is extremis as so it's like the prime
numbers folks discovering we need you to
defeat the Nazis and they're going what
yeah yeah yeah yeah and so it's to me
that's a really satisfying dialogue
because like my own background being in
computer science philosophy then I was
probably the only person to graduate
from the computer science program and go
into a terminal degree in poetry you
know I I have lived my life very much as
a cross pollinator of these things and
so it's and and they all feel extremely
interrelated in my mind and so being
able to you know it's it's sort of like
being an interdisciplinary Yenta it's
like you you're able to put these people
that that's amazing
extremely satisfying thing if I'm
interviewing an expert and I say oh so
you're working on the same thing that
so-and-so is doing in the sociology
department and they say wait what what
yeah give me their name give me their
email address and so those moments for
me of finding these things that resonate
across those lines it's extremely
rewarding well Bryan you're living proof
that humans really do have a general
purpose brain
[Applause]
[Music]
you